تتزايد المخاوف في الداخل الروسي من تحول
البلاد الى ساحه اضافيه للحرب التي تدور
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه فالهجوم على منطقه
معارضون من الداخل ضد نظام بوتين يؤشر الى
تطور لافت خصوصا وانه ياتي بعد ايام من
هجمات بطائرات مسيره على مواقع داخل روسيا
تحطمت احداها قرب العاصمه موسكو استهداف
هذه المنطقه التي تخضع لتدابير امنيه
مكثفه كشف نقاط الضعف في الجيش الروسي
الذي بات امام موقف حرج يستدعي تغيير
خارطه المعارك واعلان الاحكام العرفيه في
المناطق الحدوديه بعد ان اثبت مقاتل
المعارض الدينس نيكيتين المنتمي لاقصى
اليمين الذي تبنى تنفيذ الهجوم قدرتهم على
اختراق بعض المناطق الحدوديه التي تخضع
لحراسه مشدده في العمق الروسي
وفق مقال نشرته صحيفه
للانتفاضه ضد سياسه بوتين وتوعد باستهداف
المزيد من الدفاعات الروسيه وهو ما خلف
حاله من القلق والفوضى
اوكرانيا التي اظهرت عده مرات قدرتها على
الضرب بعمق خلف خطوط العدو بهجمات بطائرات
بدون طيار وعمليات تخريب جريئه نفت دعمها
المباشره للتنظيم وصفه للالتهامات الروسيه
بالاستفزازيه بينما استغلت روسيا الحادثه
لتعزيز ادعائها بان الناتو يدير حربا
بالوكاله من خلال ارهابيين
وزعمت السلطات الروسيه ان الغاره اسفرت عن
مقتل مدنيين اثنين واصابه طفل